jour de marché hebdomadaire hassan où
chaque lundi le long de la semoule mais
pourquoi au fait ce jour là parce que
parisot le jour de repos étant le lundi
pour les ouvriers il était décrété que
l'adisq à jour hebdomadaire du marché
l'emprise de parisiens ça va jusque là
l'emprise de premier envoi jusque-là
d'effectivement oui saint loup a vécu au
rythme de pas raison à saint loup sur
semouse ou dans le département de la
haute saône se trouve l'une des plus
importantes aux usines de fabrication de
meubles de france
notre consommation mensuelle de boire et
de 16 cents à deux mille mètres cubes
journellement y sort de 16 cents à deux
mille morts parizeau double le nombre de
ses salariés tous les cinq ans jusqu'à
compter près de 2000 employés 20 ha du
sinn un train qui transporte la
production jusqu'au réseau de la sncf
et puis et puis c'est le déclin lent
inexorable le groupe familial né à saint
loup en 1936 est vendu en 2008
- un groupe qui était qui était puissant
dans ce métier-là qui était renommé qui
petit à petit se fait grignoter par la
difficulté ça c'est dur c'est très dur
en 2017 jean charles parisot l'un des
petits fils de jacques le fondateur
rachète le groupe familial
il dirige au total une dizaine de
sociétés qui emploie 3500 personnes en
il supprime 120 postes à saint loup mais
il est optimiste pour ce site
berceau de l'entreprise familiale
entre les compétences qu'on à saint lô
et la réalité future de moins faire
voyager les produits nous sommes au bon
endroit
si on en est là aujourd'hui c'est grâce
au sol aride par exemple qui ont défendu
leur société est aujourd'hui la société
va plutôt bien et en train de se guérir
grâce à eux à la fois aux compétences et
un état d'esprit formidable parisot
n'est pas près de fermer cinq ans non
c'est pas prévu non eux et ils étaient
venus pour travailler chez pas résout
quelques années puis repartir mais
finalement ils ne sont pas rentrés chez
eux dans leur pays d'origine l'italie le
portugal l'algérie ou le maroc
un millier d'étrangers est arrivé ici en
moins de dix ans le quart de la
population aujourd'hui on ne peut que
constater cet étrange déracinement cette
mise en marche ce provisoire qui fait
passer un village de l'ère des ateliers
de compagnon à la ville industrielle
cinquante ans plus tard saint loup
compte 25 nationalités et c'est la
communauté marocaine qui est la plus
nombreuse
lieu de convivialité et de culte la
mosquée al rahman
ce qui veut dire miséricorde ils ont
fait venir donc femmes et enfants pour
certains et ils se sont installés ici et
du fait
ils ont ils sont encore toujours là donc
ça se passe très bien pour eux ils ont
travaillé en manière pour la france ils
connaissent leur pays ils ont vécu
cinquante ans 60 ans en france
ils connaissent que la france entre
guillemets c'est pas parce qu'on va
passer quinze jours en vacances au maroc
qu'on va connaître les tendances et
connaître le pays vous vous sentez
marocains ou français français mais dont
les manques
voici le dernier est le seul magasin de
meubles de saint loup
clin d'oeil de l'histoire il appartient
à une famille marocaine saint loup a
subi la crise économique de plein fouet
face au chômage et à la pauvreté la
ville tente de résister
[Musique]